connect and USC here they
come Ohio state has six turnovers but
young players first of
all right here smooth gets to her Pei
with the crossover finish a little a
little finger roll I think that was a
little finger roll at the end attracted
a lot of bodies Juju with the decision
to make pulls up and that's where she
excels in that secondary in that
[Applause]
transition Marshall demanding it on the
side G Walkins somehow some way found a
lane and finish on the left and if I
think this place would have went
absolutely
crazy Juju another hesi at the top of
the key found a way to get it off the
glass it's the for USC that was a quick
turnover at the top of the key for Ohio
State Juju Watkins picking up where she
left
off and right here the free throw line
so they've had success when they get
into the paint ch rockins have yourself
a
day well I don't think of you're Ohio
state that you can just guard her
one-on-one might see
trapping but this is not something that
you're going to be able to allow her to
do on a consistent basis this is
deflection Padia got through a
deflection there Juju rock is at The
Rim adds on to
[Music]
this Juju Watkins Z Step Go
andova look at the face though she can't
be guarded and family front row it seems
Taylor losing a shoe throwing it at
USC's
bench five on the shot clock the dish on
the inside Marshall textbook put it on
the Highlight tap standing court side
with Juju all right Juju intense
physical game down to the very end what
gave your team the edge
man uh I feel like we're underrated at
this point and so we have to come out
here and get the dub as a team that's
all that matters come out here get the
dub do whatever it takes Lisa Leslie had
30 points in her freshman debut you got
32 what does this moment signify for you
personally man I mean it's an honor I I
just come out here and play uh this is a
big a lot of practic is leading up to
this game and I I just had to come out
and show what I can do for my team put
up those type of numbers and honestly
it's a part of that USC Legacy so I'm
glad to be a part of that um and I only
go to show what we can do now speaking
of you said this is a new era of USC
basketball what did you show the nation
today about what it means to be a Trojan
out there man don't underestimate USC I
mean we're on the rise we're in the gym
24/7 working on ways to get better come
out here and play our opponents and get
the dub that's all that matters all
right congratulations on that win back
to you all thanks